[Musik]
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck big
cassemistisch auf das kommende Jahr
errechnet mit einer Schrumpfung der
Volkswirtschaft um 0,4 Prozent die
Bürger sind von der Regierung
verunsichert ich auch wie nie und ein
Politiker spricht mit so einem neuen
Buch die ticken doch nicht richtig aus
was viele Menschen denken und ganz
zufälligerweise sitzt dieser Politiker
heute Abend auch hier bei 8:15 Uhr
herzlich willkommen Karsten Linnemann
hallo Carsten Linnemann ja ich freue
mich sehr ich
stellvertreterparteivorsitzender CDU und
schreibt in seinem Buch bald musste ich
erfahren dass ich mit meinem Elan allein
in Berlin nicht durchkomme warum
politische Arbeit desillusioniert und
wieso Deutschland ein Mentalitätswechsel
braucht das werden wir heute Abend von
ihm erfahren besonders freue ich mich
auch über die Anwesenheit von der
investigativchefin der Welt einer dowidl
sieben Monate lang hat sie mit ihrem
Team und ihrem Team vom politiko über
die Geschäfte von Bill Gates
recherchiert über das Ergebnis ihrer
Recherchen und ob an den Corona
Verschwörungstheorien mit Blick auf
Gates eigentlich etwas dran ist darüber
möchten wir heute Abend sprechen
Karl-Heinz Funke ist Politiker und Bauer
in seiner Zeit als Bundesminister für
Ernährung Landwirtschaft und
forstenverband er seine Expertise in
beiden Fächern ob ihm die bauernschleife
in der Politik geholfen hat darauf bin
ich gespannt per Hendrik Rinke
kliemstein ist Unternehmer und
wäschereichef die Gaskosten machen ja
auch uns zu schaffen aber vor allem auch
den Unternehmern und seiner Wäscherei
geht es gerade nicht gut wie die Politik
Unternehmern helfen muss und kann das
bitte uns erklären und damit herzlich
Willkommen zu viertel nach acht Herr
Linnemann in ihrem neuen Buch die ticken
doch nicht richtig heißt es im
Untertitel warum Politik neu denken muss
und sie haben uns ja auch heute Abend
eine These mitgebracht über den
Mentalitätswechsel
absolut deutschland braucht ein
Mentalitätswechsel es hat sich
spätestens durch Corona eine
vollkasko-mentalität durchgesetzt jeder
versteckt sich hinter Gesetzen will
keine Verantwortung übernehmen in den
Talkshows bei Corona
Bundespolitiker hat die Verantwortung zu
Landespolitik geschoben anderer wiederum
zu Kommunalpolitik und da müssen wir
raus ich möchte eine Mentalität des
Machens dass derjenige der eine Idee hat
einfach mal losläuft ohne dass da immer
einer ist und sagt es geht nicht weil
ich habe einen Vorbild ist der
Oberbürgermeister aus Rostock der Mann
heißt Madsen ein Topmann weil der
richtig mutig war der hat einfach mal
gemacht in der Krise und hat de facto
Klick and meet erfunden indem er gesagt
hat im Einzelhandel der Kunde anruft
oder im Internet bestellt kann er die
Sachen abholen ganz Deutschland hat es
nachgemacht wenn wir dieses im Deutschen
Bundestag
diskutiert hätten werden sofort die
Bremser und Bedenkenträger gekommen und
es wäre kaputt gewesen diese Idee und
deswegen möchte ich eine
Föderalismusreform von unten das in den
Landkreisen jeder was ausprobieren kann
Abstand nehmen kann von Gesetzen und
wenn etwas funktioniert Rollis im ganzen
Land aus wenn es nicht funktioniert wann
hat es in die Tonne einfach mal machen
ist es immer noch ihr traumhell in mein
Bein als ich das Buch gelesen habe hatte
ich schon das Gefühl dass sie sehr
diskussioniert sind sie sind in der
Politik gestartet und hatten wie ich es
in dem Buch entnommen habe andere
Vorstellungen als es dann wirklich ist
ist es jetzt ihr Traum oder sagen Sie
dieses verkrustete System den
politischen Betrieb kann man erneuern
also grundsätzlich zu zum ersten Teil
ich habe mir das alles anders
vorgestellt in der Politik ich wollte
wirklich die die Welt verändern und ich
weiß nicht ob ich blauäugig war oder
naiv aber ja ich wollte die
Bildungspolitik zu einer nationalen
Aufgabe machen ich wollte den Bierdeckel
von Friedrich Merz umsetzen wo eine
Steuererklärung drauf passt ich wollte
Bürokratie abschaffen und ich weiß noch
mein Vater der hatte eine Buchhandlung
und er sagte wenn mein Sohn jetzt in die
Politik geht damit die Bürokratie
endlich abgeschafft ich habe dem das
immer gesagt heute sagt er zu mir
seitdem du drin bist nimm die noch mal
richtig zu richtig so und deswegen habe
ich mir jetzt auch die Frage gestellt
das kann nicht so weitergehen so und
deshalb ist meine These die Politik ist
nur im krisenmodus unterwegs nur in
krisenmodus erst war die Finanzkrise
dann die Energiewende dann die
Euro-Krise dann die flüchtlingskrise
dann die corona-krise jetzt die
ukraine-krise und in jeder Krise sagt
man wenn die Krise vorbei ist dann
packen wir das mit der Bildungsreform an
Bürokratie schaffen ab und so weiter und
dann ist aber schon die nächste Krise da
und damit muss Schluss sein kurz um die
Krise darf nie wieder als Entschuldigung
gelten für etwas was man in der Zeit
nicht macht als ehemaliger
Bundesminister teilen Sie das was Helene
man sagt sind sie auch desillusioniert
worden nein
bin ich überhaupt nicht das teile ich
nicht ansonsten teile ich weitestgehend
diese Analyse bis auf einen Punkt
vielleicht brauchen wir einen
Mentalitätswechsel das erinnert mich so
an Kohls moralische Wände von der
gesprochen hat ich glaube die Mentalität
ist in vielen Bereichen sehr wohl da
aber wenn zum Beispiel zum Beispiel
etwas zu machen
ich hatte einen Freund leider viel zu
viel verstorben der klassische
Unternehmer eigentlich nach Schumpeter
wie der den Unternehmertyp definiert hat
der große österreichische Nationalökonom
aber genau das war der Punkt der hatte
eine Idee wenn wir zusammen saßen sagt
der Mensch das wäre doch was denn musste
ich ihm sagen
sagen aber nicht morgen an sonst wird
deine Baustelle wieder stillgelegt weil
ja ich merke es überhaupt nicht sich mit
den ganzen Unwegbarkeiten die jetzt auf
ihn zukam zu beschäftigen und das
widerspricht auch dem klassischen
unternehmertypus mit all dem was damit
zusammenhängt so sie haben die
Landkreise angesprochen sagen sie stand
Landkreise Städte und Gemeinden ist viel
besser als auch Hamburgs aber glaube ich
auch darauf verständlich aber machen so
und wenn Sie heute
sehr konkret
ich hätte noch mal nachgemessen wenn ich
gewusst hätte dass dieses Thema kommt da
stehen 12 Häuser das sollen in dieser
Reihe von 12 Häusern zwei genau nein
gebaut werden wie glauben Sie wie dick
ist die Akte um das zu genehmigen
die ist so dick für zwei Häuser im
übrigen wo die Kinder des Eigentümers
bauen sein da gibt es auch keine
Probleme mit Nachbarn überhaupt nichts
essen und das ist Irrsinn schlichtweg
Irrsinn ist es ihnen denn gelungen als
Bundesminister in Ihrem speziellen
Bereich damals die Bürokratie abzubauen
aber Sie müssen da auch mit der eigenen
Klientel mit den eigenen Leuten sehr ins
Gericht gehen ich will Ihnen folgendes
sagen da haben sie einen neuen
förderbestand der geschaffen wird von
der EU Landwirte kriegen Geld und jetzt
geht es darum wer bearbeitet die
entsprechenden Anträge da kommen die
Landwirtschaftskammern unseren das
müssen wir aber machen dann kommen die
Ämter für Agrarstrukturen nein viel
besser ist es das ist bei uns aufgehoben
wird jeder kommt und sagt eine Aufgabe
für uns
auch stellen damit zusammen damit hängt
Beförderungen zusammen und so weiter und
dann müssen sie eine Entscheidung
treffen als du häufig habe ich auch
manchmal machen müssen wenn dann
Kompromisse gemacht sowohl als auch
angetreten damals als basta Kanzler und
sie waren doch sein Minister also was
passiert das mit dem Bass da ist Unsinn
das ist gröbster Unsinn das hat
irgendjemand mal in die Welt gesetzt wie
das so ist aber er ist auch gerne so
aufgetreten Herr Schröder wenn man sich
alte Videos anguckt ich war damals noch
ein bisschen zu klein damit kann ich
jetzt nicht komplizieren aber das hat
man ihm abgekleidet und guter Zigarre
nein ich habe es ja im Kabinett erlebt
so und das Schröder nicht ab konnte zu
Recht ich weiß ja nicht wie es in
anderen Kabinetten gewesen ist wenn
jemand über einen bestimmten Vorgang
über eine Kabinettsvorlage lange
oberflächlich diskutiert wurde da Brache
ab und sagte mach deine Hausarbeiten der
konnte man den Kram auch wieder
Unternehmen und neu wieder versuchen die
Kombination durchzubringen norddeutsch
sagen wir Gesabbel konnte er nicht ab
und das ist richtig und vernünftig das
ist nämlich auch regierten aufzuhören
mit dem Gesabbel was es gibt und zu
sagen sag was du willst es ist richtiges
falschen hat er den Vorteil dass man
sich noch sagen er konnte sehr schnell
Vorgänge erfassen auch wenn die nicht
unbedingt mit seinem angewolften Wissen
zu tun hatten aber sehr schnell erfassen
und die musste man in der Sitzung auch
beantworten können das erwartete er von
seinen Fachministern und da sagt er
schon mal kommen ja schlecht gemacht
sehr sehr Barsch vielleicht auch aber
ich habe mir sagen dass sie das war bei
anderen auch so ich als für notwendig
weil du wieder wie sehen Sie das denn
ist in der Politik zu viel Gesabbel wie
es gerade genannt auf jeden Fall ich
finde aber ein bisschen Herr Lindemann
was Sie gesagt haben der mir gesagt wenn
man im Landkreis ist und dann macht man
einfach mal und dann soll man auch keine
Gesetz achten sie haben das
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen überspitzt
formuliert und gar nicht so gemeint ist
ja schon ganz gut dass man Gesetze
beachtet die gibt es ja aus einem Grund
und ich finde ein bisschen sie haben
gesagt vielleicht war es naiv in den
Politik reinzugehen und das nicht zu
erwarten vielleicht ist es wirklich ein
Stück weit naiv gewesen denn man weiß ja
dass eigentlich das Wesen der Demokratie
ist dass man eben auch den Vorteil
dessen hat dass da verschiedene Leute
mitreden dass da eine Meinungsbildung
und Willensbildung stattfindet auf Basis
dessen dass verschiedene Parteien die
verschiedene Leute gewählt haben dazu
sagen kommen dass man dann Kompromiss
findet und das ist doch auch das was
worüber wir uns eigentlich freuen können
es gibt in der Demokratie
einfach so mal entscheiden dass das
nicht nur eine Person ist eine Partei
macht aber wenn es nicht zu viele Leute
die da mitreden wir blähen die ganzen
Ministerien auf in den letzten zehn
Jahren tausende mehr Mitarbeiter der
mittlerweile
42 beauftragte das
Wirtschaftsministerium hat sich fast
verdoppelt in den letzten 10 15 Jahren
es geht immer mehr da müssen wir noch
irgendwann mal einen Bild machen und der
andere Punkt ist ich möchte nicht
Gesetze aufheben aber ich spüre halt
wenn einer eine Idee hat und geht den
Bundestag und will das für ganz
Deutschland durchsetzen kommen sofort
die Bedenkenträger und sagen warum etwas
nicht geht wenn man aber vor Ort etwas
ausprobiert sind die komischerweise
nicht da und deswegen will ich es
umdrehen und sagen okay dann machen wir
es in Zukunft so es wird ausprobiert
wenn es läuft machen was überall ein
ganz kurzes Beispiel bei mir in
Paderborn soll die erste Stadt entstehen
mit autonomen fahren parallel zum
regulären Verkehr dazu gibt es in
Deutschland keine Regulierung ich kann
ihn jetzt schon sagen dass dort
wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder Jahre bis
das geht dann kommen die ganzen
mitdenkenträger und wie viel tote kann
es geben und so weiter lasst uns doch so
machen wir probieren das einfach mal aus
dem Paderborn und wenn es funktioniert
machen es alle nach so schaffen wir das
um in Deutschland
bei Corona erlebt wo plötzlich alle
andere Regeln hatten und das war ja auch
in Teilen hat man sich gedacht warum
kann das nicht national gelöst sein aber
Corona ist auch ein schönes Beispiel
warum hat man nicht bei Corona gesagt
wir probieren mal was aus wir lassen mal
eine Stadt das machen will
wir lassen den Einzelhandel mal offen
machen parallel eine Studie schnell und
schauen ist es wirklich so dass im Fach
Einzelhandel im Brautmodengeschäft im
normal also Brautmodengeschäft ist ja
auch ein schönes Beispiel ob die
überlaufen sind während Corona wage ich
auch mal zu bezweifeln aber auch ganz
normale
Kleidungsgeschäfte ja und dann prüfen
wir das vor Ort und wenn es funktioniert
lassen wir den gesamten Einzelhandel in
Deutschland auf evidenzbasiert wurde
nicht gemacht es wurde hier diskutiert
in sogenannten
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und dann
kam das raus was sie gerade beschrieben
haben fragen wir einmal den Unternehmer
in der Runde was halten Sie denn von dem
Vorschlag dass die Politik mal mehr
macht vor Ort und weniger debattiert
also das wäre wichtig weil ich glaube
man merkt auch jetzt gerade in der
aktuellen Krise das zu viel geredet wird
es wird zu viel lamentiert und immer
wieder werden Expertenkommission
gegründet man muss einfach mal machen
und das ist gerade wichtig die
gaspreisbremse ist eigentlich ein
Beispiel dafür wir haben in ganz Europa
wir gehören zu den letzten Ländern die
gerade darüber diskutieren und uns
sprechen teilweise davon dass ihr mehr
als April eingeführt werden soll und da
muss es einfach viel effizienter sein
also Politiker sollten sich auch ein
bisschen Beispiel an Unternehmer nehmen
wo man einfach mal auf den Tisch hauen
sagt wir müssen das jetzt mal machen das
ist eigentlich schon echt richtig ich
glaube ich noch einen Beitrag das dürfen
sehr gerne machen glaube ich nicht davon
gesprochen dass man sich nicht an
Gesetze hält er hatte einen Stichwort
genannt das ganz wichtig ist
Verantwortung wir haben eine gewisse
personale und institutionelle
verantwortungsbeweigerung ich könnte ihn
in raummengen aus der Kommunalpolitik da
bin ich auch über 40 Jahre drin dazu
nennen ein Vorgang der eigentlich völlig
klar ist wo man sogar die die beteiligt
werden müssen schon im Vorwerk gefragt
hat können wir das so machen so
Fachbehörden zum Beispiel ja ist in
Ordnung und jetzt sind sie bei einem
Beamten und wenn man dem dann sagt du
ich habe schon telefoniert die machen so
mit ruft den an das ist erledigt ja aber
wir müssen noch mal das im schriftlich
machen dann sind wir auf der sicheren
Seite und jetzt sehr konkret und
tatsächlich war es so dass sie in einer
Stunde dreimal das Wort von einem
Beamten können dann sind wir auf der
sicheren Seite ein Unding und darum geht
es in Wirklichkeit die Bereitschaft
Verantwortung zu übernehmen auch wenn es
anschließend mal schief geht und da wäre
mein Appell an die Politik diesen aber
Ministerium oder sonst wo der bereit ist
auch mal zu sagen ja machen wir so auch
wenn es anschließend Kritik gibt den
müssen wir dann auch in Schutz nehmen
was die Bürokratie ist angeht gehe ich
mit ihnen vollkommen mit also das
erleben wir auf jeden Tag wenn wir was
recherchieren wenn wir wollen wenn wir
was rausfinden wollen von Ministerien
oder von Ämtern oder von Behörden dass
wir da nicht so einfach eine Auskunft
kriegen sondern dass man sich immer
absichern will und dass man auf die
Zuständigkeit von anderen Behörden
verweisen das ist für uns auch
wahnsinnig frustrierend und da gehe ich
mit Ihnen voll der Kur ist doch schön so
viel Einigung bei einer These ich bin
mal gespannt wie es jetzt bei meiner
teesor dann ist es gab nämlich übrigens
auch ein mentalitätszwechsel in der
Union und mein Thema heute Abend ist der
quotenwahnsinn in der Union der zu
nichts führt sie haben es vermutlich
alle mitbekommen die Frauenquote kommt
in der CDU in Niedersachsen gab es
bereits Paritätische Listen die Wahl in
Niedersachsen wurde jetzt trotz diesem
feminismus-ruck vergeigt besonders
merkwürdig 2020 hat sich noch der
Parteivorsitzende Friedrich Merz gegen
paritätisch besetztelisten ausgesprochen
betitelte diese als fragwürdig und
sprach von einer Diskriminierung der
Männer jetzt sitzt hier Helene mal neben
mir und da frage ich mich jetzt
natürlich Herr Lindemann werden sie denn
jetzt kritisiert also diskriminiert von
ihrem eigenen Parteichef als sein Vize
durch die Frauenquoten nein ich werde
nicht diskriminiert dafür bin ich zu
selbstbewusst nein ich bin auch kein Fan
von Quoten ich finde das Quoten auch
nicht zu CDU passen weil wir vom
einzelnen ausgehen und ihn nicht nach
äußerlichen Merkmalen definieren
aber das war eine Abstimmung es gab eine
große Debatte und ich akzeptiere jetzt
das Ergebnis
im Kern werden wir aber das was wir
eigentlich lösen müssen dass wir mehr
Frauen auch in der Politik haben auch
bei uns nicht mit einer Quote zentral
lösen können meine Vorsitzende in
Paderborn die heißt Corinna Rotte wer
mehr als 4000 Mitglieder eine tolle
junge Frau die hat auf ein Parteitag
gesagt eine Quote wird nie sicherstellen
können dass meine Kinder von der Kita
abgeholt werden wenn ich auf einer
politischen Veranstaltung bin und damit
hat sie es auf den Punkt gebracht wie
wir die Union denn jetzt noch
konservativ rüberkommen also ich meine
die Union hat ja eh durch die
merkeljahre am Profil verloren das
glaube ich würde wenn sie mir vermutlich
zustimmen auch wenn sie CDU-Politiker
sind aber jetzt kommt die Frauenquote
was kommt denn als nächstes die
diversitätsquote also wo will die CDU
hin das fragt man sich ja schon als
Bürger
also das muss finde ich eine Ausnahme
bleiben es ist ein langes Thema wie
gesagt ich akzeptiere das Ergebnis ich
glaube das gehört auch dazu dass man
sich streitet und hinterher das Ergebnis
akzeptiert und die die wir müssen es
jetzt schaffen durch Formate anfangs-
und Endzeit dass das klar ist dass wenn
jemand beispielsweise im Ausland
studiert will aber trotzdem an der
Ratssitzung teilnehmen dass das auch
Hybride funktioniert dass es digital
funktioniert und vieles mehr wir als CDU
müssen jetzt insofern unsere Wurzeln
eine wichtige Wurzel haben sie
angesprochen ist die konservative
insofern prägen dass wir jetzt in
konkreter Politik das deutlich machen
und das machen wir jetzt im
grundsatzprogrammprozess da werden wir
jetzt im nächsten Jahr also bis Ende
September nächsten Jahres alle
Positionen durch deklarieren wie stehen
wir in der Rente wieder fällt nee das
ist eine Partei Entscheidung aber wir
werden natürlich konservative Position
haben ich bin
nicht nach der Niedersachsen
weil paritätischen Listen haben es auch
nicht gebracht hätten wir vielleicht gar
nicht gebraucht nein das hat andere
Gründe glaube ich für diese Niederlage
wenn man ein anderes Thema nein
entscheidend ist dass die CDU eine
Partei sein muss die die Bock macht auf
Zukunft wo man weiß wofür sie steht die
auch konservative Position die sie auch
mal hatte die man nicht über Bord werfen
darf jetzt die Schuldenbremse
beispielsweise ist mir viel zu wenig wir
brauchen eine schwarze Null dass der
Staat mit dem Geld auskommt ich weiß es
immer schwierig in solchen Krise so was
auszusprechen aber deswegen mache ich es
von solchen Punkten brauchen wir mehr
eigentlich will ich das am Ende des
Tages
jedes CDU-Mitglied nachts 3 Uhr geweckt
werden kann und sofort sagt erstens
drittens dafür steht die CDU hoffentlich
ist da nicht einer der drei Punkte
direkt die Frauenquote wenn man die
Mitarbeiter gehen aber er Funke da
möchte ich sie gerne einmal fragen also
Deutschland mich hat das schon sehr
bewegt Deutschland debattiert über die
Gaspreise über den Ukraine Krieg wir
sind ja wirklich in schwierigen Zeiten
und dann kriegt man plötzlich medial mit
und die CDU debattiert über die
bankquote wie ist es denn bei ihnen
angekommen das interessiert niemanden
außer den die in Parteien sind also ich
bin überhaupt nicht in den letzten
Monaten das heißt irgendwie muss ich
jetzt sehr lange nachdenken um zu wissen
wann ich auf Frauenquoten angesprochen
worden bin aber es hat niemanden
interessiert ich finde sie nicht ganz
das Klientel für die Frauenquote ja ich
weiß nicht wenn sie überprüften wie sehe
ich dafür gesorgt habe dass Frauen an
guten Stellen kandidierten dann würden
sie vielleicht etwas anderes darüber
reden aber es kommt das ist doch der
Punkt man muss doch praktisch
Frauenpolitik machen so und wenn Frauen
Männer manchmal keine Rücksicht darauf
nehmen dass Frauen keine Kinder zu Hause
haben das könnte ich in konkret sagen
wenn Sitzung über Gebühr lange dauern da
kann man vieles anders machen auch damit
Frauen dann auch mehr Interesse haben
oder mir geneigt sind mitzumachen weil
sie wissen es wird auf die Rücksicht
genommen nein aber die Frauenquote
interessiert doch in diesen Zeiten
niemanden
aus der Bevölkerung heraus für den
normalen Menschen den kleinen Mann die
keine Frau interessiert das Thema
überhaupt nicht oder ich habe einen
völlig falschen Bekannten und
Freundeskreis gebe zu
das sind überwiegend Leute auf dem
flachen Lande oder aus kleinen Städten
so die jeden Tag arbeiten gehen die auch
jeden Tag arbeiten gehen müssen auch die
Frauen um überhaupt einen bestimmten
Wohlstand ich sage außerdem bestimmten
Wohlstand zu erreichen und das wird in
Kreisen diskutiert mein Gott sollen sie
diskutieren aber die breite Masse
interessiert sich doch für einen
Sozialgesetz Thema nicht die haben
andere Sorgen das soll der Facharbeiter
vom Bau seinen ganzen Tag auf dem Bauch
steht nach Hause kommt und dann soll der
mit seiner Frau die halbtags bei Bahlsen
Kekse einpackt oder sogar in Schichten
dort arbeitet sondern über die
Frauenquote diskutieren mein Gott wer
das behauptet der hat aber jeglichen
Kontakt mit den Schichten der
Bevölkerung verloren wenn Sie zustimmen
dass die große Bevölkerung ist nicht
passiert das Thema ich glaube
tatsächlich in dem Punkt stimme ich auch
mit ihnen über eine Funke ich glaube es
ist ein bisschen wirklich so ein
elfenbeinturmthema das ist so ähnlich
wie die ganze Debatte über das Gendern
dass wir irgendwie in Berlin-Mitte so
eine Diskussion vielleicht führen und
ich glaube wirklich die Leute haben
andere Probleme ich finde eine Sache ist
mir aufgefallen in den Beiträgen die Sie
Herr linnemannter Funke gerade gesagt
haben dass sie beide gesagt haben naja
für die Mütter damit Frauen in die
Politik können muss es eine bessere
Versorgung mit Kitaplätzen geben
damit die Vereinbarkeit möglich ist
damit ich länger in politischen
Sitzungen bleiben kann wenn ich in die
Politik gehen möchte aber eigentlich
müssten sie doch genauso sagen damit
auch die Väter das können wieso ist das
denn nur für die Mütter ein Thema
haben beide Männer Anstoß akzeptiert das
Umdenken statt bei 8:15 Uhr
[Gelächter]
ist in Ordnung hier werden die die
Männer schon beigebracht so jetzt kommen
wir zu Ihnen weil sie stehen ja vom
wirklichen Problemen und zwar nicht
davor wie sie jetzt in Ihrem Unternehmen
die Frauen und Männer gleich besetzen
nee richtig mein großes Problem was mit
meiner Frau dass wir wirklich von
Energiekrise betroffen sind wir haben
sonst immer als Beispiel im Monat
ungefähr 15/16.000 € an Gas ausgegeben
das ist jetzt explodiert auf 150.000
Euro Strom kommt genau noch dazu das
heißt 50% unseres Umsatzes macht
mittlerweile die Energie aus und das ist
für uns nicht mehr tragbar so schnell
können wir das gar nicht an Kunden
wiedergeben uns wird absolut nicht
untergeholfen als Familienunternehmen
oder kleineres mittelständisches
Unternehmen der Industrie wird schneller
geholfen und auch unkomplizierter und
wir wir werden unseren Betrieb
gegebenenfalls verlieren nicht wie ein
Fehler gemacht haben sondern weil andere
ein Fehler gemacht haben und es ist
nicht auszudenken dass in Deutschland
das so weit gekommen ist dass wir Krisen
mit einkalkulieren müssen und dadurch
Halt verlieren
wenn man ihn wenn man ihn führt ich habe
ja auch noch stehen dass sie ja noch
2019 bitte korrigieren Sie mich wenn die
Zahlen falsch sind haben sie noch
monatlich 35.000 für Gas bezahlt jetzt
eine 56.000 genau sie haben 2019 weil
das noch mal ein komplettes Jahr war
nachher kam er die Lockdown so wäre
schon Umsatzeinbußen und noch weniger
Gas abgenommen haben aber 18.000 bezahlt
2020 und 21 ist es dann leicht schon
gestiegen da sind wir dann aber 35.000
gewesen das bedeutet dass sie vermutlich
jetzt schon Verluste machen wir machen
jetzt Verluste natürlich also wir machen
morgens die Maschinen an und wissen dass
wir kein Geld verdienen
wir haben Versorgungsauftrag also es ist
ja nicht das was oder das was auch er
Habeck gesagt hat wir können uns jetzt
mal alles Winterschlaf begeben und
irgendwann machen wir weiter das
funktioniert nichts wenn die
Krankenhäuser beliefern wenn sie Ärzte
beliefern wenn Sie aber auch die Hotels
auch am Laufen halten müssen das
funktioniert nicht das ist nicht so
einfach wie sich das immer alle denken
oder Ministerien denken
was würden Sie machen wenn Sie
Wirtschaftsminister werden ja ist für
mich unbegreiflich was da passiert wir
hätten nicht meine man wirft uns ja
einiges vor was in den letzten Jahren
falsch gelaufen ist aber was wir gemacht
haben in Krisen sofort gehandelt bei
Corona hat es wenige Tage gedauert wo
wir sofort Stundungen erlaubt haben bei
den Steuern bei den Gewerbesteuern wir
haben 100%ige Kredite gegeben über die
KfW mit Staatsgarantie wir haben sofort
ich glaube nach wenigen Tagen die
Soforthilfe ausgezahlt klar gab es immer
Probleme hinter mit Rückzahlung so aber
wir haben erstmal sofort Liquidität er
hat doch Liquiditätsprobleme ist doch
ein ganz gesundes Unternehmen ist doch
nicht seine Schuld er ist doch kein
Bittsteller er will doch gar kein
Bittsteller beim Staat sein er nimmt
sein Leben selbst in die Hand ist nicht
abhängig vom Staat und jetzt kriegt ihr
ein exogenen Schock fachlich ausgedrückt
wo er gar nichts für kann und deswegen
muss der Staat jetzt eigentlich ganz
einfach er muss gucken wo sind gesunde
Unternehmen hier ist eins helfen und
zwar sofort mit Liquidität und er hat
einen Punkt die Ampel will den großen
zum ersten ersten 2023 helfen und den
kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen paar
Monate später ist noch völlig offen die
schauen in die Röhre und ich verstehe
die Mittelständler dass sie sagen ich
habe hier die die Schnauze voll
mussten sie sich jetzt schon privat
einschränken also wir haben natürlich
auch privat kriegen wir das genauso zu
spüren wir haben wir haben jetzt den
Kniff gemacht dass wir aus unserer
Wohnung ausgezogen sind ins Wohnmobil
gezogen sind gekündigt haben die Wohnung
und gegebenenfalls zu den
Schwiegereltern wechseln dann für paar
Monate wenn es dann zu kalt wird weil
wir dann uns auch einschränken müssen
und als Unternehmer geht man natürlich
auch voran und sagt wenn meine
Mitarbeiter sich einschränken müssen ja
es gibt immer den den Spruch von
Wolfgang Krupp wenn ein Unternehmens
oder ein guter Unternehmer frisstrocken
Brot wenn es Unternehmen leidet und
genauso leben wir das auch wir haben
unser Gehalt gekürzt als erstes um
erstmal auch bei den anderen nicht
kürzen zu müssen oder Mitarbeiter zu
entlassen das geht aber letztendlich
jetzt nicht mehr weil wir wissen vor
März April passiert dann nichts warum
warum auch immer für mich unverständlich
warum man in der Heizperiode keine
Deckelung schafft und dann wenn man
nicht mehr heizen müssen kriegen die
Haushalte nicht den Deckel was völlig
also ich habe den Verstand bei der
Politik komplett verloren Herr Funke
können Sie das Nachvollziehen in jeder
Weise in jeder Weise und diese Beispiele
bekommt man ja auch sehr wert wenn man
unterwegs ist und mit den Leuten spricht
aus mittelständischen Bereich
wir haben ja grundlegende Fehler gemacht
in der Energiepolitik ich wäre dankbar
wenn man das mal aufarbeitete dann weiß
ich dann kommt das Argument dass uns
nicht zurückgucken lass uns voraus
gucken das führt nur dazu dass ich
identische Fehler die früher gemacht
habe wieder machen insofern ist immer
die Aufarbeitung der Vergangenheit
notwendig um Fehler die gemacht werden
jedenfalls dann bin ich schon mal gesagt
hat neue Fehler sind und nicht alte so
wir haben in der Energiepolitik in den
letzten 15 Jahren von mir aus 10 20
Jahren horren und Hut gemacht auch das
was Fachleute immer gesagt haben man
muss auch sehen dass das jetzt passiert
was meinen Sie ganz konkret was wir
falsch gemacht haben
wir hatten 2001 ich muss jetzt aber ein
bisschen ausholen dann mit der
kernenergiewirtschaft Rot-Grün ein
ausstiegsvertrag gemacht bis 2023 das
waren etwa die Abschreibungsfristen
außer kennen Energie auszusteigen hätten
wir das gemacht hätten wir keine
milliardenentschädigung an die
Kernkraftwerke die wir vom
Verfassungsgericht eingeklagt haben
zahlen müssen damals ist schon versäumt
worden dann auch entschieden in die
erneuerbaren Energien zu gehen bei Rot
Grün schon das hätte man gleichzeitig
machen müssen dann kam unter christlich
liberei die Aufkündigung dieses
ausstiegsprogramm mit der Kernenergie
Wirtschaft
dann zwei Elfers glaube ich habe es
richtig im Kopf
Fukushima ich war der einzige deutsche
offensichtlich der nicht wusste wo
Fukushima liegt ich habe es bis dahin
nicht gewusst und dann schmeißt man den
Hebel rum und hört und jetzt raus
das macht eine Volkswirtschaft
selbstverständlich wenn man nicht
gleichzeitig Alternativen schafft Grad
kaputt eine hocharbeitsteilige
energieintensive Volkswirtschaft kaputt
jedes Unternehmen das so handelt und von
heute auf morgen den Riemen auf eine
andere Orgel liegt macht Pleite genau
das ist passiert und man hätte natürlich
einsteigen müssen dann noch vermehrt als
etwa 2001 in erneuerbare Energien
riesige Investitionen machen müssen
vergleichbar 20er 30er Jahre damals in
Leitung also Infrastruktur sonst hätte
man das auch mit den erneuerbaren
Energien ja nicht geschafft enorme
Kapital freisetzen müssen staatliches
und privates Kapital so das ist wirklich
versäumt worden der Krieg offenbart doch
nur eine katastrophale Energiepolitik
ist nicht wenn man von Ursache und
Wirkung spricht das entsprechende
Verhältnisse
Bart eine unsinnige Energiepolitik die
früher unter Schmidt und Kohl getragen
wurde von drei Grundsätzen Verfügbarkeit
Bezahlbarkeit
Nachhaltigkeit das haben wir damals noch
nicht gesagt sondern
Umweltverträglichkeit so was haben wir
heute wieder Verfügbarkeit es hat immer
Leute die gesagt gegeben die gesagt
haben ihr könnt euch nicht zum abhängig
machen von einem einzigen Lieferanten
innerhalb der Union weil das wird
natürlich jetzt die Frage an Herr
Linnemann sein
in allen Parteien gab es Leute die
sagten so geht's nicht und die auch
Sachen selbstverständlich wird sich
Russland bei aller Vertragstreue die man
denen unterstellen kann der Moment
kommen 30 Prozent der Welt verfügbaren
reservengas liegen in Russland die das
als Hebel benutzen um innere zwischen
Wohlstand zu schaffen das liegt auf der
Hand wegen Monopolist oder Oliver macht
das nichts und dumm sind die Leute doch
nicht so also von der wusste man wir
müssen wie ist die Fachleute
diversifizieren ich würde mich doch in
Sachen Energie zu Hause nicht mal
alleine von meinem Familienmitglied in
100%ige Abhängigkeit begeben wenn man
wenn es Krach gibt dreht ja den Haaren
hat nein das ist so ein Curry und wir
haben es gemacht warum sagen Sie das
ohne Verstand die deutsche
Energiepolitik ist ein Energiepolitik
ohne Sinn und Verstand Helene Mann dafür
könnte man jetzt sehr klare Worte dafür
könnte man jetzt natürlich leicht Angela
Merkel und Junioren verantwortlich
alleine
der Punkte die
wir sollten nicht so lange in der
Rückspiegel gucken trotzdem hat er recht
der Ausstieg aus der Kernkraft im Jahre
2011 gar nicht mal der Ausstieg als
solches
sondern dass der Plan fehlte wie wir
einigermaßen einigermaßen autark uns mit
Energie so versorgen können dass der
Standort Deutschland gesichert ist
dieser Plan da reden wir über
Leitungsausbau
oder Schienennetz über über ja
lng-terminals gibt es ein ganz Europa
bei uns nicht und so weiter das war ein
Fehler
aber jetzt müssen wir nach vorne schauen
und jetzt kann ich ihn eins sagen das
ist eine Geschichte das ist da läuft ja
wirklich einem eiskalt den Rücken
hinunter was was wir gerade da gehört
haben von jemanden der das Leben selbst
in die Hand genommen hat und wir können
jetzt gerne noch zwei drei Jahre diese
Unterstützungsleistungen ihm geben
selbst wenn es super liefe mit den
Unterstützung er bekommt das jetzt
sofort will der Unternehmer eine
Perspektive von uns eine
Planungssicherheit und deswegen muss man
in so einer Notsituation jetzt alles was
man hat an Angebot von Energie
in den Markt werfen alles alles und
jetzt nicht irgendwie auch in der
Notsituation da musst du dann Parteibuch
wegwerfen ist nicht das Parteibuch das
ist das Buch
was vorgestern erschienen wurde aber
deswegen guten Zweck deswegen kann man
das so sagen also ich verdiene nichts
mit nein sie dürfen damit sogar Geld
verdienen so sind wir da ja das ist
richtig aber trotzdem
nee da habe ich eine andere Meinung ich
finde auch Politiker sollten keine
Honorare annehmen wir verdienen gut und
aber das ist ein anderes Thema also
Ausweitung Kernkraft auch diejenigen die
stillgelegt wurden letztes Jahr prüfen
wie viel können wir noch nicht nur
streckbetrieb sondern wirklich so lange
das sind einige Jahre
brauchen wir die noch bis diese
Problematik einigermaßen wieder gelöst
ist
lng-terminals dort einige Jahre ich
würde den den die die Pipeline zwischen
Spanien und Frankreich bauen lassen und
zwar schnell viel liegt ja schon da mit
den Franzosen reden wir haben Gasfelder
an der Nordsee ich muss jetzt volle
Pulle auf die Agenda weil ansonsten wenn
man in zwei drei Jahren hier noch sitzen
und der Staat hat auch nicht so viel
Geld zur Verfügung haben Sie den
Eindruck dass jemand im Kabinett den
Begriff der Grenzkosten kennt
also eher als CDU-Politiker würde ich
natürlich jetzt sagen nein aber ich weiß
es nicht aber ich könnte mir schon
vorstellen dass viele wissen was
Grenzkosten sind aber trotzdem habe ich
auch manchmal das Gefühl dass eklig
unterschätzt wird was gerade hier auf
dem Spiel steht wir haben jetzt die
sechste Rezession und ist die erste
Rezession wo auf einmal unser
Geschäftsmodell wirklich in Gefahr ist
unser Geschäftsmodell also das was wir
wovon wir richtig leben wovon wir
unseren Wohlstand ja finanzieren oder zu
verdanken haben
ist dass wir günstige Energie
importieren dass wir Vorprodukte
importieren auch Massenprodukte günstig
und hier unsere duale Ausbildung nehmen
unsere Ingenieure und daraus hochwertige
Güter machen und die exportieren und
dieses Geschäftsmodell ist in Gefahr und
ich habe den Eindruck dass der eine oder
andere das so nichts erkennt und wenn
sie am Anfang das Hemd falsch zuknöpfen
kriegen sie es oben nicht mehr zu das
heißt wenn wir jetzt eben nicht helfen
und den anderen Unternehmen dann sind
die weg
kann ich morgen eine neues Unternehmen
aufmachen Weg sie sind ja jetzt beide
nicht Bundeskanzler ich würde gerne
einmal abschließend zu ihrem Thema sie
fragen wem von beiden würden Sie denn
jetzt eher Ihr Unternehmen anvertrauen
werden hier zwei sehr aussagekräftige
Plädoyers ist natürlich schwierig weil
haben wir ja gerade mitgekriegt beide
waren in Regierung die ja auch dafür
gesorgt haben dass wir momentan so ein
Problem haben
Helena mal muss ich einmal recht geben
zu corona-zeiten waren die Hilfen
schneller da es wurde uns als
Unternehmen immer relativ schnell gesagt
wir helfen es wird keiner pleite gehen
es wird keiner seinen Job verlieren und
das würde halt dafür sprechen dass
Helene man vielleicht einen Vorteil hat
auf jeden Fall wobei natürlich die
konservative meinte von der Funke
natürlich auch nicht verkehrt ist also
ein Mischmasch aus beiden die CDU
konservativ bisschen konservativer
unserer könnte was werden halt alten
Haudegen der mal auf den Tisch knallt da
bin ich jetzt so zu jung für Funke live
erlebt zu haben glaube ich würde uns
dringend gut tun damit wir wir haben
jetzt schon 39%
r39% mehr Insolvenz im letzten Monat
gehabt damit wir das hinkriegen bitte
das Thema danke sie ist heute
vorgestellt haben
solche Fälle kriegt man ja nicht mehr
schnell geordnet wenn man nicht eines
macht und das hat mir früher ja auch
über Bürgschaften und ähnliches solche
Instrumente haben wir heute auch noch
mit der Bank zusammen und staatlichen
Mitteln den Weiterbetrieb ermöglichen
ja wäre das ja de facto das nur einmal
um das kein Problem jetzt zu verstehen
ist ja nicht nur die teuren Preise die
wir jetzt haben das versaut mir die
Bücher mit den versauten Büchern gehe
ich zur Bank eben und sage ich brauche
jetzt einen Kredit weil entweder muss
ich die liquiditäten schon ausgleichen
das ist dann natürlich schon Alarmstufe
Rot oder ich gehe hin und sagt ich
investiere das was man ja auch
eigentlich möchte was der Lindner auch
sagt wir wollen einen Schutzschirm bauen
dahinter soll gearbeitet werden aber wie
soll ich denn dahinter arbeiten wenn
meine Bücher so schlecht sind aber ich
sag mal das reicht schon dass dass man
eine schwarze Null hat weil die Banken
jetzt sagen unsere Bilanzen sind jetzt
aber auch nicht so richtig gut
da haben wir jetzt gerade nicht so Lust
drauf es gibt keine gesicherten Krediten
die Banken die bürgschaftsinstrumente so
und jetzt zu Corona aber selbst wenn die
Banken noch 5% drin sind haben sie
momentan Angst oder hatten auch schon
damals Angst weil es knallt bei denen es
knallt bei ein und sie wollen nicht
deswegen brauchen Sie 100%
Staatsgarantie in solchen Fällen und wir
brauchen das Dr weil wir können so auch
nicht investieren in die Zukunft um 20
30 Prozent mehr Gas zu sparen wir sollen
ja sparen aber mit welchem Geld und
nicht nur wegen dieser Situation sondern
vor allem auch wegen ganz vielen anderen
Situationen noch zusätzlich in
Deutschland verspüren Sie ja Herr Funke
eine Radikalisierung der Bürger besser
gesagt sie glauben dass es Protesten
kommen könnte hier haben wir jetzt zum
Teil schon das muss man ja sehen mich
stimmen immer nachts nachdenklich wenn
ich wir Niedersachsen jetzt eine
Wahlbeteiligung von glaube ich gut 60
Prozent habe 60 Kameras dann ist etwas
faul die gehen nicht mehr hin und zur
Wahl und typischerweise treffe ich
am Wahltag ein Ehepaar
der Mann sagt ich bin gar nicht erst
hingegangen
so mir gefällt das alles nicht mehr
Resignation Resignation ist eigentlich
in einer Demokratie das schlimmste was
es gibt wenn niemand mit mir schimpft
dann weiß ich der ist noch engagiert
dann erinnere Einstellung dazu mit ihm
muss ich reden den kann ich auch
vielleicht überzeugen von ihm auch etwas
lernen wenn niemand sagt komm her so das
ist das Schlimmste Zeichen eigentlich
was es gibt die Frau war wählen die
wollte mir nicht sagen was Sie gewählt
hat daraus habe ich meine Schlüssel aber
dann auch gezogen so und diese Haltung
ist nicht unbedingt eine Radikalisierung
aber eine signative und das ist die
Vorstufe davon dass einem eigentlich
alles egal ist und dann profitieren die
davon die wir alle glaube ich nicht
wollen das ist meine Sorge wenn wir bei
Kommunalwahlen das läuft ja nicht erst
seit einiger Zeit Bürgermeister
Landratswahlen eine Wahlbeteiligung
haben von 40 unter 40 Prozent damit
jemand Land reden über Landrat oder
Bürgermeisterin den kann mich das ja
nicht gleichgültig lassen überhaupt
nicht ging das muss ich doch fragen
Stichwort Förderalismusreform dazu
gehörte auch unter Umständen das kann
man einfach Verfassungsrechts so fragen
wie kriege ich das wieder einigermaßen
ins Lot
Frau dovidad hier ist ja man wird ja
also investigativ schon ist er
eigentlich um die Missstände in einem
Land aufzudecken auf jeden Fall wenn man
Filme schaut und das investigativ sich
anschaut die Frage die ich mir stelle
ist nehmen Sie das auch so wahr dass die
Stimmung in dem Land gibt total also
unser Team beschäftigt sich seit ein
paar Wochen oder eigentlich schon
Monaten ganz intensiv genau mit dieser
Frage zum Beispiel jetzt akuter mit
kommt jetzt ein wutherbst kommt ein
wutwintern damit ist ja genau das
gemeint gehen die Leute jetzt mehr auf
die Straße weil sie
desillusioniert sind weil sie sagen die
Politik erreicht uns nicht mehr die
hilft uns auch gar nicht mehr und wir
erleben das halt wirklich die Leute die
da eben auch zu sehen waren in den
Bildern die Leute da auf die Straße
gehen das sind ganz oft
Menschen die zum Beispiel haben wir
gerade letzte Woche eine Geschichte über
ein Unternehmer der in einer ganz
ähnlichen Situation war wie sie der
selber so ein Protest auf die Beine
gestellt hat der sagt nee ich kann damit
nichts mehr anfangen was mir die
Volksparteien bieten und das ist eben
genau die Stunde der Populisten
das spielt der AFD zu und
schlimmstenfalls eben Leute die auch
völlig außerhalb des demokratischen
Spektrums sind die all diese Menschen
die in diesem querdenkerspektrum sind
das sind ja jetzt die die vielleicht
schon angefangen haben sich 2015 nach
der flüchtlingskrise zu radikalisieren
die es dann weiter getan haben mit der
corona-krise und die jetzt sagen
in der aktuellen Situation habe ich
einfach gar keine Lust mehr und das
beunruhigt die Sicherheitsbehörden
Verfassungsschutz und so absolut mit den
sprechen wir mal darüber was seht ihr da
für ein radikalisierungspotenzial und
das ist eines der größten Probleme was
wir politisch bei uns momentan haben das
all den Informationen die Sie bekommen
und auch Recherchen kommt der Wut Herbst
ich würde sagen er ist teilweise schon
da man sieht ja wie die Leute auf die
Straßen gehen und es bleibt nur zu
hoffen dass es nicht wirklich zu so
gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen Attacken auf
Politiker oder so führt
als Politiker sind sie ja eigentlich der
Betroffene von der Kritik der Bürger was
müsste die Politik tun
drei Sachen erstens
wir Politiker müssen ganz ganz nah beim
Bürger sein ganz nah aber sind sie das
noch
also ich rufe jeden an habe mich noch
nie durchstellen lassen bin auf vielen
Veranstaltungen
Male noch persönlich also wenn morgen
Mails kommen da antworte ich das Beruf
machen
ich versuche so nah wie möglich wirklich
dran zu sein und ich glaube auch mal ein
rundes Bar ist gerade in der Kneipe ja
und lass mich danach zwei drei Bier dass
die Leute mal wirklich die Wahrheit
sagen etc ja ich bin ja auch Bürger es
geht mir auch gegen den Strich was hier
in Deutschland passiert ich spüre das ja
wenn Sie jetzt noch 10 % Inflation haben
überlegen Sie mal was was hier los sein
kann und deswegen ist es aber meine
Aufgabe hier keine Ängste zu schnüren
sondern das zu sehen und zu agieren dass
der erste Punkt der zweite Punkt wir
müssen uns einfach mit den Themen
beschäftigen oder Werbung sie haben das
eben angesprochen die die Bürger
umtreibt das ist einfach so und nicht
diese diese also ob jetzt noch Indianer
gesagt werden darf oder ob das
rassistisch ist oder ob ein Lied wie
Layla öffentlich gespielt werden kann
Wahnsinn
Wahnsinn kann das sein Bürger wollen
wissen
die Politik so ein bisschen von sozialen
Netzwerken getrieben ist weil dann so
Leute bei Twitter sind die sagen Layla
darf nicht mehr gespielt werden man darf
nicht mehr Indianer sagen obwohl es
eigentlich gar nicht so die wirkliche
Bevölkerung widerspiegelt ist auch ein
Grund warum ich warum ich nicht bei
Twitter bin weil ich zwei drei Jahren
gesagt hat ein Kind was kein Deutsch
kann hat auf der Grundschule nicht zu
suchen es muss gefördert werden über
eine vorschulpflicht bei Twitter hatte
ich 80 90 Prozent gegen mich aber mit
vollkaracho aber richtig hart rechte
Ecke ich wäre rassistisch etc heute ist
übrigens Partei Meinung übrigens auch
ein konservativer Punkt um junge
Menschen einzeln zu fördern seitdem bin
ich nicht mehr bei Twitter weil ich will
ich will mich hier nicht beeinflussen
lassen will meine Meinung sagen so und
die Leute wollen wissen ist das Geld
sicher ist der Job sicher und die
Zukunft meiner Kinder das sind die drei
Punkte und nichts anderes das sind alles
Randthemen die so hochgezogen werden
dass die Leute das Gefühl haben das ist
die öffentliche Meinung es ist aber nur
die veröffentlichte Meinung und der
dritte Punkt und der letzte Punkt ist
das Thema Arbeit und nicht arbeiten das
treibt mich richtig um
das in Deutschland nicht Arbeit sich in
immer mehr Fällen lohnt im Vergleich zur
Arbeit wenn jetzt das neue Bürgergeld
kommt Sanktionen abgeschaffen werden
dann ist ja das gesamte
soziale Prinzip es fußt darauf dass
diejenigen die Steuern zahlen unsere
Sozialstaat finanzieren genau
das heißt wir haben ja auch eine
Verantwortung gegenüber den Menschen die
unsere Sozialsystem finanzieren wenn die
aber jetzt sehen das mit dem Geld nicht
vernünftig umgegangen wird das gesagt
wird es ist besser ich arbeite nicht
wenn wir dort noch die die
Heizkostenrechnung übernommen und vieles
mehr dann stimmt etwas nicht mehr dann
sagt diese Gruppe ich mache da nicht
mehr mit und da müssen wir aufpassen
gerade in der heutigen Zeit und da haben
wir Parteien auch eine Verantwortung
Klartext zu reden wenn die Leute das
Gefühl haben es gibt keine Unterschiede
mehr zwischen den Parteien dann sagen
die warum soll ich noch wählen gehen
Wahlkampf von wählen und ich kann nur
wählen wenn es Unterschiede gibt und
deswegen war zum Beispiel die große
Koalition die ist Gift für eine
Demokratie die dafür ist eigentlich so
gut wie gar nicht geben weil die
Menschen dann die Alternativen nicht
mehr sehen und dann wählen Sie Protest
und deswegen
finde ich müssen wir an diesen drei
Punkten ansetzen und dann kriegen auch
wieder Vertrauen sagen sie heute als
CDU-Vize nicht in eine große Koalition
gehen bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl
ich würde es nicht raten nein
wir brauchen klar das darf nicht zu
lange sein ja wir brauchen wieder
Parteien mit ganz klaren Positionen dass
wir uns auch wieder streiten das ist
nicht darum geht wer wer hat jetzt die
hübschesten Fotografen oder Fotos oder
Instagram
über das Buch reden sehr gut aber
überlegen Sie mal wann hatten wir die
höchsten Wahlbeteiligung wenn wir
komplett strackige Themen hatten wo
zumindest die großen Lager mit Ausnahmen
die es dabei auch gab mal wie bei den
Ostverträgen so hohe Wahlbeteiligung in
den Wahlen weil die Menschen Position
beziehen wollten zu den Positionen die
vertreten werden sie Verwandten den
Begriff Populismus da habe ich meine
Schwierigkeiten ja für mich sind das die
popularen waren im alten Rom die
Vertreter des einfachen Volkes die
optimalen die Vertreter der herrschenden
Schicht und ich meine Populismus jeder
sein der gewählt werden will das fängt
zu sitzen jetzt Kleingartenvereins an
wenn der nicht auch Populist ist kriegt
er nie mehr alten zustande
das Volk von mir möchte und nicht dass
ich das nicht das tue von dem ich
wirklich überzeugt bin
ein bedeutungswandeln
Populisten oder populanz sehr klar der
Populist will etwas durchsetzen und legt
sich jetzt seine Argumente so zurecht
dass er dafür eine Mehrheit bekommt er
hat seine Position
Willy Brandt hatte seine Position oder
Franzosen Strauß nehmen wir mal die
großen Populisten in meinen Augen hatten
eine Frau Kohl eine Position und dafür
jetzt zu werben rhetorische Instrumente
einzusetzen
verantwortlich
Populisten
gucken wie geht denn wohl die Meinung
und das ist das gefährliche ich komme in
den Sa Glocke wie denkt denn hier die
Kohorte und dann lange ich zu damit ich
weiß du bist ganz schnell beifallen darf
ich meine Meinung dem anpasse was ich
denke das nützt mir jetzt am meisten und
gegen den Überzeugung handle ist es ja
in Ordnung so und das darf ich nicht der
Populist der sagt ich muss hier nicht
mehr Halt kriegen aber er hat seine
Position verliert und dann ist Lindemann
besser als Funkel seine Position findet
eine Mehrheit so
Opportunismus
könnte hier wohl besser ankommen ich
übernehmen die mal eben und jetzt zum
nächsten Mal und erzählt genau das
Gegenteil weil er merkt die Leute
irgendwas
dauert zu lange Herr Funke der schön ist
wir haben jetzt alle noch was gelernt
vor einer ganz kurz Unterbrechung und
danach sind wir wieder hier und sprechen
über Bill Gates bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter bauen und
ich ernst nehmen als sogenannten
Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viert fünf Köpfe fünf
Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi der Wetten
aber niemand von dem politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit wir sind
grün roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum
wuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig uns nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz anders
also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken ich habe meinen
Beifall meine lache immer bekommen wer
kümmert sich darum niemand dID ist bald
ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt mal auch
darüber sprechen dass es einfach nicht
fair ist und nicht richtig wo ist die
Aufgabe von Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen weiter mit
dem Thema von Frau dovideit und Bill
Gates
sie dürfen ihre Teesorte abends sagen
also wir haben recherchiert zu Bill
Gates und seinem Netzwerk das Netzwerk
was die Bill Gate Foundation die größte
Stiftung der Welt umgibt und wie die in
der corona-pandemie agiert haben wir
haben festgestellt dass sowohl die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO als auch
die Nationalstaaten keinen wirklichen
Plan hatten wie sie jetzt agieren sollen
wie sie auf diese Größe Krise diese
größte weltweite Krise eigentlich
reagieren sollten was sie tun sollten
und da gab es so ein Vakuum auf das die
Bill Gates Foundation draufgegangen ist
und gesagt hat wir wissen wie es geht
wir haben dann relativ schnell Fakten
geschaffen haben gesagt welche Geld
fließt wohin auf welche
impfstoffentwickler legen wir uns fest
und anderthalb Jahre später hat man
festgestellt dass die Pläne aber nicht
aufgegangen sind das also sozusagen ein
Netzwerk was überhaupt nicht
demokratisch legitimiert war Fakten
geschaffen hat und diese Fakten aber im
Grunde genommen dazu geführt haben dass
Afrika vor allen Dingen nicht richtig
versorgbar mit Impfstoff mit
Medikamenten und mit Testkits es ranken
sich ja viele Verschwörungstheorien um
Bill Gates es war habe ich auch in einem
Interview gelesen das war auch so der
Aufhänger warum sie und das Team sieben
Monate lang recherchiert haben
welche Verschwörungstheorien sind denn
richtig welche sind falsch also wenn ich
jetzt jemanden nach heute abend sage so
schätze ich Bill Gates ein was sollte
ich sagen also Verschwörungstheorien
sind sowieso generell alle falsch die
sich um Bill Gates Ranken also es gibt
ja da diese wilden Theorien dass Bill
Gates irgendwie durch Impfungen Leuten
Chips eingepflanzt hätte das ist
natürlich totaler Unsinn und ich glaube
das ist aber auch ein bisschen der Grund
warum seriös recherchierende
Journalisten bei diesem Thema ganz lange
abgeschreckt waren und gesagt haben an
das Thema gehen wir überhaupt nicht
kritisch ran und gucken uns überhaupt
nicht kritisch das Wirken dieser
Foundation an obwohl dir so ein ganz
großer wichtiger Player ist eigentlich
der größte Spieler in der weltweiten
Gesundheitspolitik und wir haben dann
gesagt wir gucken uns jetzt mal ganz
strukturiert an was hat diese Stiftung
seit Beginn der Pandemie gemacht wo
haben die Geld eingesammelt von wem wie
viel was haben die für ein Lobbying
gemacht um dieses Geld zu bekommen was
haben sie dann mit dem Geld getan und
was ist am Ende dabei rausgekommen und
was man halt sagen kann ist tatsächlich
und ist auf die Frage nach den
Verschwörungstheorien zurückzukommen
dass die einfach diejenigen sind die die
weltweite Gesundheitspolitik am meisten
bestimmen obwohl sie niemand gewählt hat
und obwohl es auch keine richtigen
Aufsichtsgremien gibt die das Wirken der
Gates Foundation und ihrer mit ihnen
verbündeten anderen Stiftungen
kontrollieren also bis vor relativ
kurzer Zeit saßen im Aufsichtsrat der
Gates Foundation Bill Gates seine Frau
sein Vater und der Milliardär Warren
Buffett der wiederum einer größten
Geldgeber der Gates Foundation ist und
die Nationalstaaten sowie Deutschland
die USA die wiederum viel Geld geben an
die Stiftung die es dann weiter verteilt
haben überhaupt keine Möglichkeit zu
kontrollieren was passiert mit dem Geld
die geldstiftung unterstützt ja auch
einzelne Medien das ist ihnen vielleicht
auch bei der Recherche begegnet das ist
aber nochmal so ein anderer Punkt also
es gibt ja zum Beispiel den Spiegel der
eine Finanzierung mal bekommen hat für
spezielle Projekte die er dann gemacht
hat das ist aber jetzt was anderes das
haben wir uns jetzt nicht so angeguckt
also wir haben uns ja wirklich nur das
Wirken der Stiftung in der
corona-pandemie angeguckt es gibt aber
wahnsinnig viele Stiftungen
Organisationen in Deutschland auch die
Geld bekommen von der Stiftung und man
kann schon sagen die ist wie so ein naja
also wie so ein Spieler der hat überall
seine Arme drin und der kann einfach
wahnsinnig viel bewegen und viele Themen
auch auf die Agenda der Politik setzen
und wenn jetzt sagen uns ist am
wichtigsten diese Krankheit zu bekämpfen
und nicht jene dann passiert das auch
also wenn ich es einmal zusammenfasse
würden Sie sagen dass die Bill Gates und
Melinda French Gates sie heißt jetzt
wieder am Arsch mittlerweile angenommen
hat genau mittlerweile leben sie in
Trennung arbeiten aber ja noch zusammen
würden Sie sagen dass diese Stiftung
faktisch die Politik bestimmt ja zu
großen Teilen schon also unser unsere
Recherche wir haben uns da auch so
angeguckt
über auskunftsanfragen an die
Bundesregierung zum Beispiel mit wem hat
sich Bill Gates und Melinda French Gates
zu welchem Zeitpunkt aus der deutschen
Politik getroffen und wir haben dann zum
Beispiel Unterlagen aus dem Kanzleramt
noch aus der Zeit von Angela Merkel
bekommen wo man dann sehen konnte zum
Beispiel an dem und dem Tag hat Bill
Gates bei Angela Merkel angerufen vorher
da ging es um die Frage ob der
Patentschutz gelockert werden sollte für
Impfstoffe gegen Corona vorher hatte
Angela Merkel gesagt na ich könnte mir
schon vorstellen ich schwanke noch
vielleicht könnte es in dem Fall mal
sinnvoll sein das auszuprobieren nach
dem Telefonat hat sie dann sagen lassen
durch die Regierungssprecher nee wir
müssen beim Patentschutz bleiben das
sind nur so kleine Indizien man weiß
jetzt nicht hat er wirklich gesagt Frau
Merkel sie müssen aber und ich glaube
auch nicht dass die Frau Merkel so so
die lässt sich ja auch nicht steuern wie
eine Marionette die wird sich schon
durch Argumente haben hat überzeugen
lassen aber es sind eben die Indizien
Wasser einfach für eine Wirkmacht hat
das heißt dass er auch den direkten
Draht hat und sagt ich rufe an Frau
Merkels am Telefon es sind eigentlich
indizin dafür dass Bill Gates auch den
deutschen corona-kurs mitbestimmt hat
absolut nicht nur in deutschen sondern
in den weltweiten
Helene Mal wenn sie das als Politiker
hören dann denke ich als erstes Wahnsinn
die wichtig Journalismus ist ich will
gar nicht wissen wie lange das gedauert
hat was sie da gemacht haben also stark
sie haben doch vermutlich als sie die
Teesorte gelesen haben auch erstmal eine
Verschwörungstheorie gedacht als sie es
gelesen ich habe auch erstmal
recherchiert weil ich kenne natürlich
viele weltweite Organisationen und die
sind
mit dem Faktor auch für die
Daseinsvorsorge da so eine who muss ja
schauen dass es weltweit eine
Koordinierung gibt etc und immer wenn es
um Daseinsvorsorge gibt haben
privatwirtschaftliche Interessen keine
Chance oder sollten es nicht haben und
deswegen ist es extrem wichtig
gleichzeitig ist die w.ao natürlich in
den letzten Jahren irgendwie auch
runtergekommen die waren irgendwie froh
dass die Spenden bekommen haben von den
privaten und das war dann der
Zielkonflikt und die privaten haben
gesagt wenn ich euch Geld gebe würde ich
auch mitreden das geht natürlich nicht
bei einer who genau also das habe ich
eben erst noch nicht so ausführlich
gesagt also die Nationalstaaten
Deutschland USA Großbritannien die haben
in den letzten Jahren immer weniger Geld
an die WHO gegeben und deswegen konnte
die WHO die ja eigentlich für diese
Bewältigung von globalen
gesundheitskrisen zuständig sein sollte
das nicht mehr so machen die war nicht
mehr so ein richtiger operativer Akteur
sondern die ist eigentlich nur noch zur
Verwaltung von Krankheiten und zu ihrer
Erfassung da und deswegen hat sich
überhaupt die Bill Gates Stiftung
irgendwann gegründet zum
Jahrtausendwechsel und hat gesagt da
gibt's ja eine Lücke da muss doch jetzt
mal jemand aktiv werden und dann haben
die sozusagen gesagt so und das ist ja
auch da kann man ihn auch dankbar für
sein dass die überhaupt mal weil
Nationalstaaten und wir halten könnte
eigentlich auch sagen dass die Bill
Gates und Melinda French Gadget die auch
die größte private der Welt ist dass die
schon mächtiger ist als die who also auf
jeden Fall ist die WHO sehr stark von
ihr abhängig die sind zuletzt der Größe
größte einzelne Geldgeber gewesen und es
gibt auch ein ziemlich großen
personellen Austausch zwischen der Gates
Stiftung und den anderen mit ihr
verknüpfen Stiftung und der who also das
ist so eine ziemlich kleine Community
von globalen Gesundheitsexperten und die
kennen sich alle und die Stimmen sich ab
und dann geht der eine mal dahin und der
andere geht mal dahin und das ist so
eine verschwommene Gemeinschaft und da
ist schon die bildmilinda Gates
Foundation der
mächtigste Spieler da habe ich ihn als
letzte Frage für heute eine suggestive
stellen die müssen Sie auch nicht
beantworten wenn Sie nicht möchten weil
ich weiß dass sie suggestiv ist aber
glauben sie nach ihren Recherchen das
vielleicht sogar die corona-politik
anders verlaufen wäre ohne die Stiftung
ja auf jeden Fall dann ohne die
starke Einflussnahme der Gates
Foundation darauf dass dieser
Patentschutz auf die Impfstoffe
unbedingt erhalten bleiben musste hätte
es sehr wahrscheinlich mal anders
ausprobiert werden können dass man in
Afrika gesagt hätte wir entwickeln wir
wir stellen jetzt hier selber die
Medikamente her ob das geklappt hätte
oder nicht weiß kein Mensch es gibt ja
auch gute Gründe dafür man braucht den
Patentschutz sagt Bill Gates und sagen
natürlich auch viele andere die
Marktwirtschaft ich denke man braucht
Patentschutz weil sonst würde kein
impfstoffentwickler ein Anreiz haben
sowas jemals noch mal zu machen aber es
gab durchaus die Debatte zu sagen hier
ist eine noch nie da gewesene
Herausforderung für die Welt und
vielleicht hat man es einfach mal
ausprobieren können in dem Fall vielen
Dank generell herzlichen Dank an meine
Gäste es war eine muntere Runde und ich
möchte Ihnen das Buch wirklich empfehlen
wir sagen immer bei finara wir brauchen
mutige Politiker das ist ein mutiges
Buch von Karsten deine Meinung und ich
wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
machen sie es gut und bis morgen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]